li I think you said that feature writers
should have a new ready to market
feature script every six months or so
and that TV writer should have a new
original pilot every like three or four
months in a perfect world okay okay
a lot of pressure there it is a lot of
pressure I find the most features go six
to 12 months you know the truth of the
matter is if you take 14 months and you
come out with a great sample I'm not
going to hold it against you
you know the important thing for me is
that you keep writing and you keep
finishing work four pilots in a perfect
world I would like to see to generated
in a year sometimes it happens so it's
only one sometimes it happens that it's
three it really depends on the writer so
there isn't one set course that you're
supposed to follow but it really is
about doing the work and then getting
the work out there sometimes you'll work
on a script and you'll say you know I've
worked on this for eight months I've
tackled it every which way it's not
happening so it's also knowing when to
let something go not for all eternity
but potentially to come back to it later
when you've had a stroke of genius that
informs you how to take the work how to
make it better you know but the point
with having those broad goals is to just
do the work and get it out there rather
than spend years and years and years
tinkering with one screenplay that then
you're out of the risk of after three
years and I just went through this with
a writer tinkering with the same script
for three years and then going oh it's
not good enough it'll never be good
enough I'm not going to get it out there
and then starting another script and
spending another two years on something
and then going oh but it's still not
good enough I'm not going to get this
out there that is the challenge that we
run into that so because of that you
really want to expose the work early and
often so that means from concept you
want to run the concept by people in the
know whether they're members of your
writers group or in a class or whatever
it is have people look at your outline
really don't be afraid to expose the
work to get feedback to have questions
asked I was just sitting with a writer
of mine who had written a script a
feature script with the guidance of his
manager and they had been on the script
for a year and a half and then he gave
the script to a few writer friends
and he got some massive notes back and
what he said to me is only we've given
it out on outline which is what we all
were pushing him to do but he felt loyal
to the manager he didn't want to expose
it and I understand I understand the
choice that he made it was an in a tough
spot do you listen do you serve the one
master or do you open yourself up I
generally prefer to expose work early
and often because I think it just saves
you a lot of time in the end